okay so next up Rachel Dolezal
n-double-a-cp leader have you seen these
pictures fun dip yeah I just looked
through on the internet and found a
couple of them on Twitter I gotta tell
ya and this one
everybody knows you never go full [ __ ]
thank you
I get the impression that she wants to
look like the woman from Saturday Night
Live Minnie Riperton his daughter no
well I was gonna say I heard the story
right and as it's breaking right now I
expected to see like some biracial sort
of Halle Berry kind of look you know
cheating blaring it's not even close
yeah I'm gonna stay this color she looks
like a whiter version of that that
cousin from Arrested Development she's
like and she even went with a really bad
tan
it's like Snooki with a Beyonce wig she
if you're gonna go is that a wig or did
she get a perm well here's the thing
she's very clever if you see the
pictures because she got a perm but then
she did like the brown hair kind of like
when when black women try to dye their
hair brown as opposed to black so she's
really getting into the role I mean you
look at it
she went full wanda sykes i don't know
the woman that's the woman I'm thinking
of from Saturday Night Live that is like
her if you're there's some gorgeous
black women out there and I guess she
thought the Wanda Sykes thing was the
most convenient here's what I find very
telling and people are going to get mad
at later on so if you're watching this
online the show broadcast from 6:00 to
9:00 a.m. and you can subscribe to the
podcast a three hour show and this is
likely to change but the top three
hashtags now for hours have been Rachel
Dolezal transracial and wrong skin no
there's one other one today that's
pretty big
what Jurassic world well yeah Jurassic
world I'm talking about just don't
derail there's no needed to rail this
the point is these are the three top
hashtags right now okay okay no liberal
website not one is covering it HuffPo
Vox slate Salon Media Matters nothing
I've got them in front of me and you
know you know this story broke out and
they just had to convene and say oh my
gosh which victim status supersedes the
other one what we do it is confusing to
try and navigate
in today's society well I'll tell you
why because I'll say exactly why in
trying to blur and completely eliminate
gender lines while widening America's
racial divide through identity politics
they're creating that line with the
giant sharpie leftists have found
themselves and they're in a real
dichotomy here because as this
transracial movement and even though
this may not be transracial let's be
fair she could just be lying to get a
leg up there is an actual transracial
movement enough for it to hashtag as it
begins to take shape leftists have to
make a decision
are they racist in supporting this
blackface charade or are they
transracial phobic in not supporting
this blackface charade they have to pick
one of them there can be no other choice
and a big part of this I know you're in
the the transgender side of the movement
but in in painting anyone who logically
opposes the neo transgender movement by
painting them as hateful now leftists
have over they've painted themselves
into a real corner that's where they're
finding themselves yeah
now of the way I figure you know if I
were to be able to get and improve my
race to something different it would be
a race lift that's where they need to go
if they're gonna go with this there
should be you know surgeries for it get
a race lift you go where you need to go
well you can't say that if someone's
soul as a woman and they're a man then
you can't say well some of my soul is
black how do you tell them no how do you
tell them not I did grow up on a lot of
Motown music yeah you grew up in Livonia
yeah yeah but I could pick up this
incredibly what we do play the bass I
think that's a prerequisite if you're a
boy yeah there we go
I am I'm but this is just please leftist
the overreach is glorious continue with
the overreach and by the way anyone
listening podcast YouTube watching
remember this when leftists say oh
you're just saying you're saying that
black people are feminists they're
transgender that they're out there
reaching trying to achieve victim status
for political gain do you really think
they do that that's absurd here you go
here's this is obvious is an extremely
goofy coat I'm gonna play the Newfie
card play the free card this girl who
was white wanted to claim to be black to
be able to use the
scarred the victims status she wanted to
ace claim to be Native American to to
get Warren yeah yeah yeah
well she made a living this one made a
living off of it with the n-double-a-cp
she talked about experiencing the chains
of her forefathers said her father was
black about being pulled over while
black this is what people want now and
you talked about this fun dip and your
rant against against fat pride in in all
pride but oh yeah fat pride game I have
anything in life some work debt exactly
in trying to create identity not through
your actions not for your
accomplishments leftists have given
people pride in things they were born
with people now aren't seeking out you
know I guess acts of Valor for example
kids wanted to become war heroes because
I'm going to be proud like grandpa d-day
or at that point like dad on d-day I
want to be a man who wanted to die like
all of his ancestors Lieutenant Dan yeah
maybe he had an uncle that died in the
Civil War great uncle that died you know
he said he win when Forrest saved him in
Forrest Gump
he was brokenhearted that's true have to
get Gary on the show the point is people
no longer take pride in their actions in
their principles they're they're told
they're supposed to take pride in gender
and race and so that's what people now
strive for to be black to be gay to be
transgender to be whatever this is if
there is an overreach leftism right now
has overreach they've jumped the shark
you went full [ __ ] man never go full
[ __ ] sure to subscribe by clicking my
face here on YouTube clicking the video
next to me or subscribe on iTunes
SoundCloud or loud or with Crider com
it's all free and I'm sure many of you
will still find a reason to [ __ ] about
it